now you're excited by the possibilities
of nanotechnology of Nanobots
of being able to do things inside our
body inside our mind that's going to
help
what's exciting what's terrifying about
Nanobots
what's exciting is that that's a way to
communicate with our neocortex because
it's each neocortex is pretty small and
you need a small
entity that can actually get in there
and establish a communication Channel
and that's going to really be necessary
to connect our brains
to AI within ourselves
because otherwise it would be hard for
us to compete with it in a high
bandwidth way yeah yeah and that's key
actually because a lot of the
things like neuralink are really not
high band with him
so Nanobots is the way you achieve high
bandwidth how much intelligence would
those Nanobots have
yeah they don't need a lot uh just
enough to basically establish a
Communication channel to one nanobot so
just primarily about the communication
yeah between external Computing devices
and our biological
thinking machine
what worries you about Nanobots is it
similar to with the viruses
well I mean it's the great goo Channel
challenge yes
um
if you have a nanobot
that
uh wanted to create any any kind of
entity
and repeat itself
and was able to operate in a natural
environment
it could turn everything into that
entity and basically destroy all
uh biological life